so all-american let's talk about that
that song are you going to change it to
all Canadian tonight or what I don't
need to be your natural but I know I
girl I already did that and I well I
started in North Bay okay and so um you
know we I had a plan before you know
months ago I called it because I like
we're changing the song all-american all
Canadian now you know I pay homage to
all right yes so what would tell me I
don't know if I could say this you can
see whatever you like you're an ass man
yeah booty and so I wrote a song about
it and as you didn't Canadian women are
beautiful and they have nice butts as
well so you're gonna have to pay homage
to them I like it perfect so when you
travel you know around the world are you
just going to change it to different
countries or Canadians respect you know
I try to in certain countries and did I
think I was like in Brazil I was like
all Brazilian or like where else I've
you know have tried it in Japan yet or
but or maybe like so it works some
places and some places it doesn't some
places not so much yeah now I know
you're focused on this tour which is
very exciting but Vegas is coming up
mm-hmm how excited are you for this and
is this a dream come true it is because
that when you as a as an entertainer and
especially in the last you know five
years Vegas has really become the mecca
of you know if shows you know not only I
mean you hear about the most incredible
shows being performed there then yes the
Cirque shows you know you got Jail oh
you got Britney had Celine Dion who
really kind of kicked it off and so as
an entertainer to be able to be in one
place and then also have that production
value increased so that you get it
perfected yeah everyone is trying to
they're challenging each other out there
and it really pushes you know
the artists to deliver show unlike
anything that their fans have ever seen
so we're excited about that you know one
location the people can kind of come
into and you know a huge production
along with our catalog of thankfully a
lot of hits so it'll be great to see it
who are you looking to do you go to jail
Oh showed you go to Britney's show to go
to Ord you go to all the shows and take
bits from them or do you just do your
own thing you know we've seen like a lot
of the shows out there and there's
definitely some things that that I think
you know we actually [ __ ] we're going to
share the same stage that you know
Britney and JLo are on yeah so there's
going to be some things that maybe we
can pull from but for the most part you
know every I think every artist has
their own identity and things that
they're trying to put into it yeah so
we're in the pre-production phase of it
right now and coming up with some really
interesting things I feel like you need
a Canadian point of view like if you
need me to go down and when I give you
my opinion when the show starts I feel
like we could do that I think that's
what we're gonna do yeah a phone call
okay I say they all sacrifice yeah I
just want to help you really ha - see -
yeah what's that we'll just set you in
the theatre yes just right in the middle
by yourself yes and then we'll perform -
this year I feel like we are on the same
page okay this is Ricky what do you want
to see from that show um I want to see
well I I expect us to exceed anything
that we've ever done yeah and deliver
something that is entertaining from top
to bottom that has energy that
that brings you on a ride you know
through our history from from the
beginning to to where we are now and you
know obviously keep a nice amazing
production you know over the tops gags
crazy things and then also dancing and
performing being us you know do what